1973 le premier ministre du royaume uni
a le sourire aux lèvres pour le tous
c'est un jour historique
le coeur après plus de dix ans de
négociations la grande bretagne entre
enfin dans la communauté économique
européenne
la cee nous avons beaucoup de choses à
partager de nombreux britanniques
heureux et plein d'espoir pourtant au
départ le royaume uni regarder de loin
la communauté européenne se construire
déjà lié à d'autres unions
il ne voyait pas l'intérêt d'adhérer à
cette nouvelle alliance mais en 1961
l'économie du royaume est en berne
contrairement aux six pays de la cee
alors l'alliance des voisins attise la
convoitise
cette même année le royaume demande
solennellement à y adhérer
le général de gaulle répond deux ans
plus tard lors d'une conférence de
presse
la grande bretagne a posé sa candidature
au marché commun
le discours est long alambiqué
l'angleterre en effet l heure est
insulaire est les maritimes
la conclusion de ce monologue le général
de gaulle ausone son veto pour lui après
l'heure ce n'est plus l'heure et surtout
les britanniques ont posé quelques
conditions pour rentrer dans la cee
hors de question qu'ils aient un
traitement de faveur bref la nature
la structure la conjoncture qui sont
propres à l'angleterre diffère
profondément deux seuls des continentaux
laporte europe claque au nez des anglais
en 1967 de nouveau le royaume uni dépose
une demande là encore le général de
gaulle y répond lors d'une conférence de
presse le mouvement qui semble porter
actuellement l'angleterre à ceux liés à
l'europe au lieu de se tenir au large
ce mouvement ne saurait que satisfaire
la france et c'est pourquoi nous prenons
acte avec sympathie
voilà le président français prend acte
avec diplomatie certes
mais aussi avec une petite touche de
condescendance il prend acte donc et
refusent une seconde fois il faudra
attendre 1969 et l'élection de georges
pompidou pour que la situation se
débloque les conversations succèdent aux
rencontres et finalement elles
aboutissent rondement menées par des
politiciens de grand talent en 1973 le
royaume uni rejoint donc la communauté
économique européenne
de quoi ravir les politiciens qui y
voient une promesse de croissance
mais dès le départ de nombreux
britanniques ne sont pas convaincus par
cette alliance
[Musique]